hey guys I'm Greg I'm telling you you
might be asking yourself why do you not
have a shirt on in this video my Batman
swim trunks my bad man
sweating trunks that's the way dude I'm
gonna do this the whole video so we're
gonna watch the trailer today there's
two trailers actually for injustice to
the gods among us not the gods among us
gods among us I'm excited for this I
genuinely am I don't really do game
trailers Tony plays a lot of games yeah
I don't really
I started playing injustice gods among
us on the video game app and as of 40
minutes ago
I finished the story mode goddamn it's a
good [ __ ] game like I love this is
gonna be kind of a long intro guys but I
love the story of injustice I thought it
was so brilliant to give us everything I
have ever wanted from like a collection
of these heroes it was able to focus on
each character at the right time it
always advances story took them to
locations that you wanted to go to like
seeing Superman as a bad guy was great I
will start off with the reveal
announcement trailer yeah I waited to do
this for so long because I wanted to
finish the game and this is the first
time where there's like a story to a
game and I have played the latest
installment of y means yes it's easy to
play of winning it like feels like more
combat means oh yes so cool
Kings you ready tones him man oh [ __ ]
oh man oh [ __ ] dude the graphics are so
much cooler holy [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh yeah
I'm loving this hell yeah damn right
you're stronger oh man nice
[ __ ] a man a monster is that Bryan
Cranston talking watch
ah you can't [ __ ] with the back oh [ __ ]
heyo each time
my onyx
kind of looks like a Batman Beyond kind
of thing every battle defines you do you
I love it
I [ __ ] love it I'm excited it looks
like everything's all Bionic and shoes
getting like Bionic suits well it makes
sense this after what happens you know
like know when Batman rebuilt like you
know he gets all the Luthor's money and
I'm sure like with the Utopia that the
world becomes there they're able to make
even more advancement in technology I
love their graphics they look so good
though because the story mode is so
amazing I love the story so much to know
that the graphics I've like gotten so
much better and you have the engine and
you're rebuilding the game you don't
have to really like work on a lot but
just upgrading it so I just feel like
this is just gonna have nothing but like
upgraded gameplay I'm pretty sure the
game plays out already Anna yeah I think
we're gonna watch the trailer in a
second I love how even in this they're
just like no we can't let Batman get out
I love the whole thing with his masks
getting crazier and crazier those
kryptonite arms he has that could be
that's the best way he could fight
against Superman there tonight that
would make his life a lot easier
get some kryptonite I mean crippling
armor is just gonna we're gonna be like
fighting like in a Tron stuff yeah you
know it's cool but the new suit of
Batman's it looks bad man beyond
inspired
oh yeah the red is in the back man yeah
especially like the Batman Beyond and it
takes place like it's more futuristic
and stuff I mean I'm sure there's an
inspiration for that because there is a
love for that show they see so far like
they were all familiar characters
despite Supergirl you know I want to see
who the new characters are maybe they
could throw in my zoom on there that'd
be awesome you could play fight out zoom
that's a cool character along with flash
man yeah be cool to include red hood I
think that'd be sweet yeah that conflict
with his son Damian at one point like
more to the bat family to be included be
cool could you another print Supergirl
on this it would be cool to like see
some more expansion because I just love
Nightwing Nightwing
my all-time favorite foursome I'm I feel
like it might be a little too futuristic
like a little too advanced because you
know a lot of these games do that now
everyone kind of has like an Iron Man
suit at this point I think the day when
these guys make Marvel vs. DC that's
when shit's really gonna be like [ __ ]
awesome I want Jesse Eisenberg's Lex
Luthor to be in there oh I want it
specifically that Lex Luthor I want them
from an alternate universe and I want
that alternate universe to be the
universe from Batman V Superman and then
I wanted the Dark Knight universe to be
intertwined too and then with the 1970s
Superman well and the nineteen and I
mean the the Superman Returns movie I'm
not done Tony and then eventually yeah
intertwined with the Batman
you know the one with Adam West and then
then think I'm done and then we get the
birds of prey from the one of his WB
when they have birds of prey she was
Batman's daughter that was the only hook
I can't wait to get the mobile app we're
about to watch the injustice to official
gameplay reveal trailer just wanted to
see everyone fight
all right see if that body armor comes
into play
Wow oh whoa whoa [ __ ]
I guess their alibis
Oh
oh wow what's going on there oh my god
there's so much going on Batman V
Superman knew what I loved about their
x-rays like I know that they're X
raisins I don't know exactly what
they're called you're testing my
patience that's what I always like and
whenever they lose they get up for a
second then will they make up for not
having like the crazy sadistic violence
like what Mortal Kombat has they make up
with settings a lot you know like now
they like start flying into another set
pretty [ __ ] nuts they take you to
another part that you want to be a part
of they make you feel a part of the city
a lot of the time and I love that they
were doing that there I want to see why
Batman is fighting Superman in space and
not space in the sky I'm pretty sure
that yeah those are like the x-rays like
that's how crazy their game how or
Superman knocks them into the sky yeah
and we got some cool new characters the
way gorilla grodd's throwing down is
[ __ ] fantastic well that's scary
it's a [ __ ] ink coming at you gorilla
I mean this man Supergirl looks like
she's [ __ ] killing him and that x-ray
vision on that it's great marketing too
because a Supergirl show does so well to
get show I want to tell you yes yeah
urge it all together I love it it's the
most gritty show I've ever seen great
great ease the word AC Black Manta for a
second it's throwing down on Aquaman
that was pretty sweet too I want to see
more of his powers
I want more footage of black mantas
powers Black Manta set named for Tony
nope not gonna say it you wanted to say
it but you know what I want to say
see always like the background like the
design on every level and I'm pretty
sure these ones are gonna be asked like
way more in-depth than like the ones
from any previous game just having like
that engine before
I'm injustice the first one like just to
build on it it just looks like they just
Howard this up so much more that's what
I always loved about like the second
game it's just like they have the engine
already it's just time to make this like
enhance and make it way more better
payment supergirls fighting uh I think
it's names Atrocitus both of them looked
really great because Supergirl looks
[ __ ] sweet and because she's adorable
too and Atrocitus like he looks [ __ ]
terrifying
oh no they said when I thought about in
Catholic school like when demons and
stuff the only thing Devils anytime
there was like I played those big
characters just see hell it always
seemed a little slow but Aiden I'm
pretty sure you got some badass powers
on and you look badass
anyway ya know this game looks like it's
gonna deliver even more I'm excited I
can't wait to get the video game app
I'll get the actual game - please
subscribe I want you to makes my heart
feel full of joy mm-hmm
Tony what's your gamertag you know
chronic bomber yeah go there and what's
your Instagram trees yeah there go there
follow me on Instagram Twitter Facebook
and you let let everyone know that I
love Obama